- What's up Believe Nation?
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
I started the Did You Know
series to try to learn
a little bit more about some
of our famous entrepreneurs
that we love and look up
to and try to give you
some new facts and little
behind-the-scenes things
that maybe you didn't know before.
And, so today we're going to
learn nine surprising facts
about Warren Buffet.
(lively music)
(bell ringing)
Fact number one, he bought his first stock
when he was 11 years old.
- I got my first stock
in the spring of 1942.
I was 11 and if you remember,
you don't remember (chuckles).
No one watching this will remember,
but we were losing the war at that time.
We were getting, we were getting
totally creamed in the South Pacific
and the Philippines fell and
the death march at Baatan,
and all that sort of the thing.
It was not until the battle of Midway,
which was a little later,
that things started turning around.
But, I was optimistic on the country then.
And, I've been optimistic on
the country ever since then.
And, incidentally, the Dow
Jones Average then was 100
and it's 17,000 now (chuckles).
No one has ever been a success
betting against America
since 1776 and they're not going
to be a success in the future
doing it either.
(numbers rattling)
(bell ringing)
- Fact number two, he was
rejected by Harvard University
and subsequently went to
Columbia where he mentored
under Benjamin Graham.
- So, when you graduated
from University of Nebraska,
you applied to Harvard Business
School and were rejected.
- [Warren] That's true.
- Has Harvard ever announced that they've
regretted that decision?
(audience laughing)
- I understand the Development Officer's
kind of unhappy (laughs).
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
- So, you rejected by Harvard, you went to
Columbia Business School
and then you met the man
who you really idolized, Ben Graham.
And, when you took his
class, was he as great
as you had thought he was going to be?
- He really was.
He only taught one semester, one class.
And, he came up from Wall
Street and taught this class.
That's the reason I went to Columbia.
And, I knew what he, I'd
already read all the books
and everything, but it was inspirational
just to be around him and
it made a real difference
in my life.
(numbers rattling)
(bell ringing)
- Fact number three, he reads
five to six hours a day.
- I should mention one
thing about reading,
it was at the library here
at Columbia that at which
I spent probably more time
than any other student.
I lived there practically.
But, you know I pulled a book out there,
happened to be Who's Who in America,
and it told me something
about my professor,
Benjamin Graham, and then I looked up,
I went to the library and
I said I want to learn more
about this because I
learned this over here,
that changed my whole life.
We own GEICO now because of
that librarian directing me
to some other book and then
following through on that.
It's the chance, I read about
1/5 the pace that Bill does,
but I still spend five or
six hours a day reading.
I mean it just, you can learn so much.
I particularly love biography.
Just to be able to live the lives
of these people that have been,
that seem so extraordinary
and the lessons,
the discouragements they faced,
just everything about it.
So, you can't get enough of reading.
(numbers rattling)
(bell ringing)
- Fact number four, he plays
bridge 12 hours a week.
- If I'm playing bridge
and a naked woman walks by
I don't even see her (chuckles).
Don't test me on that (chuckles).
- [Host] When he's not counting
money, he's counting cards.
Buffett plays bridge
about 12 hours a week.
- I one time said that I
wouldn't mind going to jail
if I had the right three cellmates
so we could play bridge all the time.
In fact, I might even prefer it.
- Are there lessons for business,
for later life in this game?
- Well there's a lot of lessons in it.
You have to look at all the facts.
You have to draw inferences
from what you've heard,
what you've seen.
You have to discard improper theories
about what the hand has as more
evidence comes in sometimes.
You have to work with your
partner particularly on defense.
- [Host] Not to say that
bridge will ever be as big
as it once was, but you can
do worse than heeding advice
from Warren Buffett.
- I've never met anybody
that spent the time to learn
the game that didn't consider it
one of the great things in their life.
(numbers rattling)
(bell ringing)
- Fact number five, he earned
money by delivering newspapers
as a kid and he still loves doing it.
- [Narrator] Buffett says
that from delivering papers,
he learned the importance of
hard work and reliability.
- And, I also learned, frankly,
that if you did a good job,
you were going to move up.
The very fact that I did a
good job in Spring Valley
got me the Westchester routes later on.
- [Narrator] Getting the
five-building Westchester Complex,
home to Washington's
elite, transformed a job
into a business.
By the time World War II
ended, Buffett, not yet 15,
had saved what an average
American earned in a year.
- I was fortunate in that
I was here during probably
the most interesting period
you could be in Washington
during World War II.
I mean, I delivered the
papers when Roosevelt died
and when the atomic bomb was dropped.
- [Narrator] Newspapers remain
close to Buffett's heart.
He owns several and a
newspaper tossing contest
is a regular event at
his Berkshire Hathaway
annual meetings in Omaha.
(crowd cheering)
- I still like to deliver papers.
I anybody's got an open
paper route out there,
I'll be glad to help him out on it.
(numbers rattling)
(bell ringing)
- Fact number 6, he drinks
five Coca Colas every day.
- I drink probably five
12-ounce Cokes a day.
And, that's about 700 calories.
And, I've been doing it
more or less all my life.
I can't imagine anybody
that feels better than I do.
I mean, I'm happy, I enjoy life.
And, I've always wondered
if I'd had a twin,
and he had to eat broccoli and asparagus
and Brussels sprouts
and done it every day and
I'd been drinking my Coke
and eating potato chips
and there's some cookies
that also have 100 calories per ounce,
which of us, I think the
other guy would be gone.
I mean, I think he probably
would've committed suicide (chuckles).
And, he certainly wouldn't feel
as good about life as I do.
I feel good every day.
(numbers rattling)
(bell ringing)
- Fact number seven, he was awarded
the Presidential Medal of
Freedom by Barack Obama.
- [Host] As a world-renowned
investor and philanthropist,
Warren E. Buffett's
business acumen is matched
only by his dedication to
improving the lives of others.
He is a co-founder of the Giving Pledge,
an organization that
encourages wealthy Americans
to donate at least 50% of their wealth
to philanthropic causes.
Warren Buffett's example of
generosity and compassion
has shown us the power of one
individual's determination
and inspired countless women
and men to help make our world
a brighter place.
(crowd applauding)
(numbers rattling)
(bell ringing)
- Fact number eight,
if you invested $10,000
with Warren Buffett in 1956,
it would be worth $500 million today.
(upbeat piano music)
- I formed my first
partnership in May of 1956.
So, this was the year-end balance sheet,
which I typed myself.
In fact, you'd probably
find a few typos in it.
And, these are my partners
I had at the time.
And, this was my father-in-law.
That was my roommate in college.
That was his mother.
That's my Aunt Alice.
That's my sister, Doris, and
that's her husband, Truman,
and that was the gang.
- And, you.
- If they kept the $10,000
investment and then
when I liquidated the
partnership, reinvested that
in Berkshire Hathaway, they would now have
about 500 million.
(numbers rattling)
(bell ringing)
- And, fact number nine, he
loves playing the ukulele.
- And, this is Warren Buffett singing
Frank Sinatra's My Way.
- Joined by Piers.
- I will do a bit of
murmuring in the background.
- Let's do it here now.
♫ And, now the end is near
♫ And, so I face the final curtain
♫ My friends I'll say it clear
♫ I'll say it something or
else of which I'm certain
♫ I've lived a life that's full
♫ And, traveled each and every highway
♫ And more, much more than this
♫ I did it my way
- Fabulous (Piers claps)
- And, that's as far as we go.
- That was absolutely fabulous.
- That's a lot of talent.
- And so, no, it's my
great pleasure and honor
and I'm more nervous now than
I've been on stadium stages,
but Mr. Warren Buffett and I
are going to perform for you.
- Thank you and this has been described
as a once-in-a-lifetime experience
and you'll understand why.
Once will be enough.
(audience laughing)
- Then again, once you
get a taste of these girls
yelling for you, sir...
- Well, I'm sure of that.
(audience laughing)
Finally groupies.
I've been waiting all my life.
(audience laughing)
Now pay particular
attention to the first line
because this is what it's all about.
♫ You've got to give a little
♫ Take a little
♫ And let your poor heart break a little
♫ That's the story of
♫ That's the glory of love
♫ You got to laugh a little
♫ Cry a little
♫ And let the cloud roll by a little
♫ That's the story of
♫ That's the glory of love
♫ As long as there's the two of us
♫ We got the world and all its charms
♫ When the world is through with us
♫ We got each other's arms
♫ You've got to win a little
♫ Lose a little
♫ And always have those blues a little
♫ That's the story of
♫ That's the glory of love
- We did it.
(audience cheering)
- [John] Ladies and gentlemen.
- So, thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed this fun video.
I'd love to know what did you guys think.
Leave it down in the comments below.
Which fact was the newest one
for you or did you not know
or do you want to add a 10,
11, 12 to the list as well?
Share you thoughts in the comments.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.